[Music]
well our daily cancellation today is
like a russian nesting doll of dumbness
you start with something dumb only to
find that there's something dumber
inside it and then something even dumber
inside the dumber thing and so on
forever ever and ever into the abyss on
final analysis when surveying the whole
web of idiocy in its entirety you're
left with something so inconceivably
ridiculous that it would be too
outlandish even as a babylon b headline
okay that's how i'm setting this up and
i and i don't think i'm exaggerating
we begin here as we start to peel back
the layers on this onion of idiocy
there was a group of computer
programmers
who invented
the world's first ai rapper okay so
imagine siri or alexa if they were drug
dealers and you basically get the idea
here the robot rapper is named fn mika
and he has over the past year or so
apparently released a number of songs
despite not actually existing in
physical form that is a handicap which
has not prevented him from creating
masterpieces like this one
[Music]
okay
who knew that the singularity would be
so obnoxious and yet it must be admitted
that fn mika also sounds
indistinguishable from most other
rappers this a.i generated song
is lifeless and empty and depressing and
terrible and for that reason it's
totally at home and
amid today's landscape of rap and pop
music it's not it's not that it's not
that artificial intelligence has become
so sophisticated it's rather that
popular music
has become so atrocious this is the
great twist ending to the story of of
humanity it's the thing that no sci-fi
writer saw coming they all thought that
computers would gain souls and become
like humans
but instead humans lost their souls and
became like computers
and because most popular music is
soulless and hollow it can be supplanted
by you know siri's ex-con boyfriend
even the pop songs ostensibly created by
human beings are still for all intents
and purposes artificially generated the
average beyonce song has like 25 writers
and yet the lyrics sound like something
dr seuss might have written if he was
brain damaged and addicted to crack
cocaine
there's no truth or beauty or soul in
any of it and so nothing is lost by
replacing modern pop stars with actual
robots
capital records certainly felt that way
which is why they signed fn mika last
week gave him a record deal making him
the first non-existent person to ever
obtain a record deal as the website hot
new hip hop noted at the time the rapper
is the creation of brandon lee and
anthony martini of factory news which is
a a virtual record label that was the
first to sign the robot martini claims
that the rapper's voice is that of a
real human but everything else about him
from his lyrics to the chords and tempo
underpinning his music is based on a.i
fn mika is a big sign for capital
records as the virtual being has over 10
million followers and a billion views on
tick tock ryan rudin of capital records
describes mika as this way it meets at
the intersection of music technology and
gaming culture it's just a preview of
what's to come
yes a preview of what's to come or so he
thought
a few days after capital records had
triumphantly announced its partnership
with a semi-literate chat bot the
partnership had tragically come to an
end
fn mika
despite not actually existing
was cancelled
because he used the n-word
that's correct a non-existent artificial
robot rapper was fired because he used a
racial slur that a million actual human
rappers have used a million times a day
stereo gum reports quote capital records
has severed ties with the recently
signed ai rapper fn mika who came under
intense scrutiny after clips of the
project using the n-word went viral
social media users also surfaced an old
image from mika's instagram showing that
uh the rapper is in a scene of police
brutality
capital record center statement cmg has
severed ties with fm mica effective
immediately we offer our deepest
apologies to the black community for our
insensitivity in signing this project
without asking enough questions about
equity and the creative process behind
it we thank those who have reached out
to us with constructive feedback in the
past couple of days your input was
invaluable as we came to the decision to
end our association with the project
well it's a good thing that they
apologize to the black community this uh
will come as a relief to all of the
ordinary black people who were feeling
deeply traumatized and emotionally
burdened by the inappropriate language
used by a rapping computer program
except of course that no ordinary black
people were traumatized by this or even
aware of it this was this was the work
of brain dead activists who complained
that fn mica was a caricature and
stereotype of black culture
and they're correct of course i mean
it's exactly what it was
except that
most human rappers
are also caricatures of black culture
they are more cartoonish and insulting
in their case you would think the
caricature is even more degrading
because there's a human being behind it
and if the n word is objectionable which
it is
you would think that the offense would
be all the greater when an actual flesh
and blood human rapper utters it
but that's not the rule as outlined in
the book of wokeness according to those
scriptures the rules are pretty clear
the n-word is a magical incantation
which is empowering and positive when
uttered by black people but horrifying
and dangerous when it passes through the
lips of someone with a lighter skin tone
it is a combination of syllables whose
offensiveness is determined by skin
pigmentation and if you have no skin
pigmentation at all because you have no
skin because you don't exist then you're
not entitled to say the word
and that's all there is to it
there's no logic to this rule there's no
sense there's no moral coherence but
there is consistency at least
never mind the fact that the programmers
use the voice of an actual human
who happens to be black to generate fn
mika's voice
in fact it's not clear to me that fmica
actually is an ai at all it seems that
he's essentially a computer animated
avatar
voiced by an actual person i mean he's
not a robot any more than buzz lightyear
or shrek or robot
but but i don't know forget about all
that
nothing needs to make sense in the world
of of the woke scolds
all they know is that they are outraged
the reasons don't matter
and today they are outraged by a
computer animated avatar
and that is why they
along with that avatar are cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts